My husband doesn't eat cake,
but it is his birthday in the morning
and he requested his mom's chocolate cake.
So when everyone went to bed, I started baking.
I combined some water and butter in a pot
and let that boil on the stove before whisking in some cocoa powder.
I poured that into my dry ingredients,
cracked an egg in it,
added some sour cream, and beat that on a low speed.
When it all came together,
I poured it into my sheet pan
and popped it in the oven for about 20 minutes.
While that's baking,
I clean up my workstation before moving on to making my frosting.
Frosting is very simple.
Add some cocoa powder,
sour cream, and some milk before I sift in some powdered sugar,
mix that until smooth and spread it all over my cake.
My husband doesn't really like celebrating his birthday,
but I decided to make it just a tad more special
by putting up some decorations.
I decided on a golden black theme for his birthday birthday,
so I got some balloons that would match that
and put them up on top of our stove
and also on the ceiling.
I got this birthday banner and thought it would be a lot bigger,
but nevertheless
I put it up and sprinkled some of these Golden Star
confetti on in the kitchen counter before packing his little gift bag.
Lucky! And I don't do surprises that well,
so I already got Him his birthday presents a while ago.
So this wasn't the big present.
Then I unpacked all of my candles and prepped them for the morning
before I wrapped up my cake and finally went to bed.